[Music]
so far we've understood what conditional
probability is and seen a practical
example wherein we use the conditional
probability to predict the outcome of an
event
now in this video we are going to solve
an example based on it
if a family has two children then what
is the probability that both children
are girls given that in the first case
at least one is a girl and in the second
case the youngest one is a girl
also we have to assume that each child
born is equally likely to be a boy or a
girl
now here we have to find the conditional
probability for both these cases
so let's begin
first we will write down the sample
space
we will represent the elder child with a
capital letter
and the younger one with a small letter
there can be a total of four
possibilities
both the children are girls the elder
one is a girl but the younger one is a
boy it can also be that the elder child
is a boy and the younger one is a girl
or both the children are boys
this is a sample space a list of all
possible outcomes prior to knowing any
given facts or conditions
now if you're asked to find the
probability such that both the children
are girls then there is only one
possibility out of the four
hence this probability will be one by
four
but we've not been asked this regular
probability
what we are asked is the conditional
probability that both children are girls
given the condition that at least one is
a girl
which means if we know that at least one
of the children is a girl
based on this known condition
what's the probability that both
children will be girls
now let e be the event that both the
children are girls and f be the event
that at least one is a girl
hence we need to find the probability of
e given f
now the probability of e given f is
equal to p of e intersection f upon p of
f
let's find out p of e intersection f
first
the event e intersection f is the
intersection of the events when both the
children are girls and when at least one
is a girl
hence there will be only one element in
the intersection
now what about p of f
the event f will have all those possible
outcomes where at least one child is a
girl
hence the sample set will be written as
shown
now that we have the sample sets ready
let's find out the probabilities
p of e intersection f will be the number
of possible outcomes of a intersection f
by the number of total possible outcomes
this will be equal to 1 by 4.
similarly p of f will be equal to three
by four
hence p of e given f will be equal to
one by four by three by four which is
equal to one by three hence the
probability that both children are girls
given that at least one of them is a
girl is equal to one by three
now similarly you can solve for the
second case so give it a try and post
your answers in the comment section
below
in the next video
we shall see one more important question
based on conditional probability
so see you in the next one
[Music]